from what I understand this is the story
of the people who try to steal the Death
Star plans which drives the plot of a
new home I wonder if they'll succeed I
haven't felt this much suspense since
Titanic introducing Galen or so a hero
so heroic that he's never mentioned once
in the original Star Wars trilogy thanks
for building the Death Star off DUP so
we could destroy it dick
it's not a Star Wars breakfast without
some mysterious blue liquid why does
this ship land so fucking far away from
the home it's here to investigate why
double d's keep doing this you're on a
spaceship just land 20 feet from the
house is there any reason why gala needs
to wait for these guys to walk to his
farm so far away why hasn't he already
run away if his daughter can get away he
can too and don't tell me he knows about
building a Death Star and putting
weakness in it yet that comes later
having already seen this movie I kind of
wouldn't mind if instead of jumping
ahead in time they'd have just stayed on
young-jin growing old with Forest
Whitaker
a Star Wars story in movie stormtrooper
ties are much larger and cooler than any
other I got to play with back in the 80s
considering that they had this hiding
place that the discount stormtroopers
can't find was there really any reason
anyone had to die okay she's in space
prison but where does this open door the
camera is backing through lead to is the
prison apartment with multiple rooms
this is essentially the fourth of eight
movies and the Star Wars franchise that
focuses on either the Death Star or
something like the Death Star get your
head out of your Death Star Star Wars
congratulations you are being rescued
good god I might have to start removing
sins just for the fact that Alan Tudyk
exists to dig come on moving I know we
have a lot of characters to meet a
little time to do so how am I supposed
to keep up with ring of Katherine Jetta
well Bonnie and this place
god damn this movie changes planets
faster than it guardians of the galaxy
film what is this it's a chance for you
to make a fresh start we like using
prisoners for make-or-break missions in
fact we're also waiting on Sean Connery
to finish getting a haircut
while we D thaw sliced alone and they'll
meet up with Jason Statham for transport
here this is captain Cassie and and old
rebel intelligence aka discount han Solo
also one happy Mon Mothma is in this and
they got the same actress from Revenge
of the Sith to player but we're the was
she in a new hope this is kind of
confusing since she was the main rebel
leader and returned to the Jedi where
they're building yet another Death Star
but as you know that's way down a line
from a new hook we're hoping that he
would help us locate your father and
return him
to the Senate to the testimony you gotta
love when someone walks in on cue just
to show they're in the movie and
bridging continuity between the prequels
in this one that's basically his role
here you find him you kill him boss dude
tells kasi and to kill Galen if they
find it the guy that designed the
supposed planet killing weapon you don't
ask that guy a few questions maybe tear
gate him trust goes both ways but
neither of you trust each other even a
little bit this is one of those things
you say that sounds cool but makes no
fucking sense he's not trusting you nor
is he asking you to trust him ah
frightening CGI decisions also you
couldn't find a guy who looks like grand
moff tarkin you found someone who looks
enough like Mon Mothma I'm sure she was
in Revenge of the Sith dude that doesn't
mean you can't go on a casting call for
new Peter Cushing's this fucking
mind-reading Jabba ripoff with a dozen
tentacle penises that's pretty insanely
useful but I'm wondering how did saw end
up hiring Bor goeth or did he just come
with the Kate Pride this you just call
back to a new hope is call back what do
you know about Kaiba Christos my father
he he said they powered the jedis light
sabers is it just me or are the Kyber
crystals this movie's midi-chlorians in
other words things that rob you of the
mystery of star wars this line not only
makes a little sense it's never returned
to were paid off in any way it's just
random pseudo force poetry the guardians
of the wheels unless you have subtitles
the names of these things in movies are
totally confusing I heard this as
guardians of the Wills in a movie
theater but apparently it's guardians of
the Wills and now I gotta figure out
what the a will is oh it's the force
well the scene does a good job not
letting you know where anyone really is
and an even better job making you not
care I sure would like to see what
cassian is seeing right now I might
enjoy this action scene a lot more
did you know that wasn't me this is
almost remove as sin worthy but this is
a disobedient Android right here and how
the fuck did Kate 2's own over June and
casseon work Donnie Yen is a blind force
attune Star Wars character is such a
match made in heaven I'm not taking a
sin off the universe is stormtrooper
suddenly has alarmingly great aim when
it comes to hitting a stormtrooper being
used as human shield go back to the ship
wait for my call oh now he obeys after
ex machina disobeying and saving their
lives can you get us to Silver Arrow no
but all his soldiers who are
eavesdropping nearby just now can Jeddah
is nothing if not a place for convenient
timing that seems like a long walk to a
super obvious place for song Guerrero to
have been hiding all this time
but whatever the Empire is leaving cats
and dogs living together it's madness
hollow porn land this movie game in the
oxygen problem to pad the runtime from 2
hours 14 minutes to 2 hours 15 minutes I
mean yeah right we call it the death
there is no better name and the day is
coming soon when it will be unleashed
well it will be unleashed in mere
minutes on this very city
so pre-recorded Galen is pressing in as
here on accident has placed a weakness
deep within the system movie tries to
retroactively Lee excuse the Death
Star's ludicrous weak spot but fails
because that weak spot is still so
stupidly obvious someone in the Empire
should have noticed that long before
Luke trust of the force also Galen err
so created the small champ that Luke
will one day fire his one-in-a-million
one-in-a-million shot into winning the
day for the rebels but if he had this
kind of power in creating the Death Star
surely he could have figured out a way
that would not have required such long
odds there's literally no reason for the
Death Star to cause a total eclipse on
Jeddah before annihilating Jeddah city
cool shot that in no way makes sense
even lead the plans the structural plans
for the Death Star to find the reactor
why didn't Galen go ahead and send the
Death Star plans to saw yeah yeah the
plans are on some other planet but why
not at least sent a drawing or some if
he could get this message to saw surely
he could get the plans or a drawing to
him casseon uses a thing on an
inexplicably placed prison door
controller and makes his escape ah Star
Wars the universe we're merely shooting
a lot makes it unlock somehow this is
possible while this is also going on and
nobody important dies in the scene you
know Hollywood not everything exciting
has to occur at the very last second in
order to be exciting think about the
serendipity here the rebels find Jin in
a prison on some distant planet take her
to the rebel headquarters and send
casseon with her to go find Saul then
the Empire tests the Death Star on the
a planet where saw is he shows her the
gang later so recording and luckily
Qasim was able to totally bolt this way
out of his cell to save Jin just in time
to fly off the planet before they died
suicide by stubbornly refusing to leave
with the others I feel nothing
he had his chances your work exceeds all
expectations said the studio to the CGI
firm after signing off and this totally
not real looking grand moff tarkin
abomination everyone survives this
literally the only way Hollywood knowns
didn't own a mountaintop walk is
dangerous is the cliche of a few rocks
falling off the path how are there not
at least six people dead after critic
just yelled fire no one here is any of
this I guess the film chalks it up to
the rainstorm but honestly that's pretty
fucking stupid also I know Jin is a
badass but a one-armed tug on this
stormtroopers gun and he goes flying off
the edge get the squadron leader on get
him on now they're already engaged then
several seconds of them flying through
the mountain peaks before they're
actually on site engaged but what
happens like this movie gives a shit
about time also didn't bode tell Cassie
and a few moments ago that getting
through these canyons was tough because
the Empire had sensors and all through
it
why were they able to fly through here
without any alarms going off this
doesn't kill nearly as many of these
assholes as you'd think it would get the
sense that this guy could have been a
Jedi but the Jedi Council hadn't passed
any a DA laws back then Jin's reunion
with her dad is prolonged by spaceships
exhaust because this movie stretches out
every single moment two to five seconds
longer than it should hopefully she gets
to him just before he dies
oh good she did hmm you lied about why
we came here and you lied about why you
went up hello well he did take the pilot
guy with him so he didn't go up alone
which if I'm being honest agree it's a
bit of a dent in your anger argument
could the Empire get any more Sauron yep
this movie's gonna use the Allred
helmeted Imperial Guard dudes even
though a new hope and Empire both had
none of them apparently just before you
got to know invader was using these red
dudes as bodyguards on the regular it's
hard to create problems has certainly
been confirmed damn
Darth Vader's beginning to sound as bad
as Bugs Bunny without Mel Blanc which is
weird since this is before a new hope
it's almost like the actor doing his
phony says 40 years older now so weird
until you can assure the Emperor the
Gaiden or so has not compromised this
weapon in any way especially in any
obvious and easily detectable way that a
child would spot instantly
like gas vents that lead back to a main
engine so I'm still in come on
he's leaving dude why would you even
risk asking this be careful not to choke
on your ass for me she's director but
Darth Vader spent some time as James
Bond from 1960 to 1962 the question is
what choice run high plead for mercy
scatter your forces movies just gonna
suddenly give the prisoner angry
daughter character not only the wisdom
for an inspiring speech but the public
speaking and motivational skills
required to make it work okay movie but
I tuned out about half a jetta ago
you're asking us to invade an imperial
installation based on nothing but hope
nice line but no she's got information
about the installations weakness as well
as legit experience versus imperial
troops Andy blind force a ninja for a
friend rebellions built on hope
yeah just like I've always believed for
this entire movie get with that yunnan
hoping pieces of no show four of us is
quite enough oh man you doing it's kind
of amazing that the rebellion didn't
think to send a small group of
volunteers to do exactly what gin is
going to do they have an impounded
Imperial ship two Imperial defectors and
they always fight when the numbers are
against them so what did they have to
lose by sending some dedicated fighters
did I do
I believe you for no reason at all other
than hell the script says I do so let's
do this road one rogue credits normally
and I'd shoot this ship down but they
promoted Gary over me friend yes I will
send for you need someone you can trust
I would trust her with my life I thought
Princess Leia was on our way to Alderaan
at the beginning of a new home and Vader
boarded their ship around the time they
reached Tatooine so sending the plans
with r2d2 to give to obi-wan was a Hail
Mary but here apparently she was sent to
see obi-wan before the rebellion even
new rogue Wan went on their own sanction
mission w00t arrival schedule new flood
station and even though there was a
rebel attack there no one informed you
of a rerouted ship because at this point
everyone in the Empire is bad at their
jobs
silver arrow used to say one fighter
with a sharp stick shut up
after everything I've sent through you
mean to tell me these men need a miracle
on ice style pep talk prior to their
battle this is the movie esteem ubi has
tried to movie on my ass and it makes me
angry
makes me angry and I'm gonna start
ranting soon I'll be looking for a
manifest that would be helpful
you know where you keep such things no
reason to be suspicious good luck
but is this what well don't you look at
that they took the clothes off the
inspection team and they conveniently
fit Cassie and Jin I've got a bad
feeling about me Oh boom ooh be
intercepted Imperial transmission mom
zone scaris even though this proves
nothing and the rebellion was dead set
against going to scare if they send
everyone there now because rebels are
the rebels decided to defy orders
if bb-8 and Ketu it so have replaced
both of you in our hearts you aren't the
droids we're looking for
move along I can locate the tape but
you'll need to use the handles for
extraction excuse me the tape did he
just save the tape watchtower
why keep it tight doesn't that just
increase the odds the cannons will hit
one of your squadron why not fan out
wide and force them to constantly move
their fire to hit one of you bunched up
together you make one bigger target
padding the XP and kill stats for
whichever Endor is Manning that
particular cannon so for these assholes
waiting for the skirmish has been going
on ten minutes geez archive footage now
so you've got CGI plastered over other
actors posing as the original actors you
have new actors replacing old actors and
now you're just reusing old footage what
was the deciding factor on all these
alas poor red 5 I knew not status that's
it because it's me yeah but what happens
if you're not the person looking for the
plants what if you die you mean to tell
me that Galen left all this to chance
this further illustrates why it was so
stupid he didn't send the plans along
with Bodhi in the first place or a copy
of them or at least a general thing to
look for when attacking the Death Star
[Music]
Jesus the radio and satellite this
finale is in confusing with all this
stuff gin and Cassie underdoing and
tandem with what bodis doing this
conflict will warp your mind into jelly
but c-3po got at least eight movies why
is she wearing Deadpool style double
swords on her back we seen her use that
kind of thing at all in this movie yeah
yeah she snuck in here and some bounty
hunter droid costume thing but still he
had your hair I'm wearing this for the
climax I never once let her use them
that's a sin for the costume designer I
think the muscle sweets a title for that
code so go
just look at the size of that hard drive
whatever it is thing and sure the death
star plans are probably a huge file but
Jesus Leia puts them inside r2d2 later
so why the empire need this much storage
this is like the Rebel Alliance having
moved on to mp3s while the Empire is
still on eight tracks guys I'm having a
hard time figuring out which character
is blind in this scene blind guy who can
see incoming blaster shots and enemies
during battle has to feel around for the
right lever on the console
I mean you made this way too hard for us
but you know good job I guess I like how
once everyone is fulfilled their one
crucial plot duty they die immediately
it's as if the bad guys know to wait 10
seconds after they finish to finally
figure out how to kill these people what
the unholy fuck is this bull the thing
to set the antenna alignment is on the
edge of this walkway for some reason
instead of where all the other controls
are misalign was it somehow hit during
this battle by a we were neck swing that
misaligned it but didn't actually damage
it do they have to realign it every time
they want to send a message out of here
my father's revenge he built a floor on
the desktop why would you say this I've
heard of the bad guy monologuing in
situations like this but the good guy
died with the rebellion dead guy ex
machina
now if they got this transmission then
why didn't everybody in the rebellion
have the Death Star plans maybe they
said only this ship could receive the
transmission but ghin used a satellite
to beam these things into space anybody
could have gotten them right look how
badly he's limping right here how did he
climb up even if he somehow knew about
and had a keycard for and then took the
same elevator Critic did he's limping
too badly to have made it up here in
time this is some of the highest order
Wow oh yeah look at that hoist it with
his own death star movie rips off to sit
on a beach in a week for the sweet
incoming death scene from Deep Impact
the rebel flagship his disciple on board
but has received transmissions from the
surface the an Arab boarding party yes
yes prepare a boarding party for the
rebel flagship but by all means allow a
small ship to fly out of it later is
this scene with darth vader badass and
awesome yes that's a contradict
basically every physical movement Vader
made in the original trilogy yes still
though this Vader scene holy seriously
why are there no Imperial ships around
to stop this it's like everybody
disappeared a minute ago they had ships
blasting the rebel flagship but I guess
they were told to vanish once Vader
boarded it by this point everyone should
know of the magnet hide a ship inside
bigger ships and do everything they can
to prevent it from leaving ah more
terrible CGI decisions perhaps even
worse than the previous ones also I
guess when Bale told Leia to go find
obi-wan she decided to put herself in
danger just in case the rebels were able
to find the Death Star plans why does
she have to do everything
I can't there be somebody else in charge
of the plans while she goes to find
obi-wan I think the connection between
this and a new hope is a bit jagged help
ah gu movie hope hope hope hope hope
hope hope say do you remember the first
movie was called a new hope hope hope
Bobbo Hope Solo the ship takes off using
hyperspace and somehow didn't get to the
planet before Vader tracks them down
[Music]
be careful not to choke on your
aspirations
now that dream is go back to this my
heart our in my deliverer George vets on
oh yes yes we are
affirmative George vets or no being
George vets will not be it some rose
lean Rogue rogue one ha ha
look down the base look down and close
the shield you better lock it up you
better lock it up
whatever I do I do it to protect you
[Music]
there's a twenty six percent chance of
failure never tell me the odds can this
these are pets of course
no white domesticated
[Music]
I would trust her with my life